okay so growing up and growing up in the
liquor business I've always learned that
it's super hard to compete with alcohol
so everybody back there do your thing if
you're not hurting feeling so thank you
so much for having me I figured to be
very honest especially as I've been
walking around the room and seeing so
many familiar faces I don't think this
one's necessarily me to sit up here and
pontificate now it's a little dark and I
was hoping to convert this a little bit
into Q&A so maybe at some point we'll
turn on the lights or I'll just I'll
roll with it but I guess the thing that
I don't want to really talk about is the
thing that I'd realized but I just spend
the last 20 years of my life on which is
attention I think if I synthesize what
I've been up to
what gives me the the honor of sitting
here in front of all of you is that at a
very young age I mean going back to
lemonade fans I when I was seven years
old I had a three lemonade stand
franchise and my friends work the
lemonade fan and I was literally this is
real and now thinking back to it it's so
so crazy I would literally think it was
fun at seven years old to walk up and
down the streets of Edison New Jersey
sit on the grass and the corners of
streets and try to figure out which
poles which trees were the most
interesting to put signs on based on
watching human beings Drive and try to
follow their eyes and figure out the
spot and as sick and bucked up as that
sound to me it's interesting that that
was literally blueprint the rest of my
life when I did baseball card shows and
I was making three four thousand dollars
a weekend when I was twelve I now
remember oh it's weird
I would actually spend the first four
hours with baseball card show walking
the entire show watching the market
coming back and then setting up my table
based on how mine was different than
everybody else and that ultimately
manifested when are we that Ultimates
manifested somewhere way out there in
Short Hills Springfield New Jersey
my dad had a liquor store and I got
dragged in when I was 14 and I basically
spent all my days 15 hours a day
Saturday and Sunday and every weekend
of my teenage and high school years
watching how people walk through that
liquor store ultimately the internet
came around and in 1996 I launched one
of the person commerce wine businesses
in America called winelibrary.com
and I went on to build that business
over three to a sixty million dollar
business on the same thesis which is
where is overpriced attention and where
is underpriced attention when I look
around this room startups consultants
VCS
you know business leaders I'm curious
because this is a smart room I'm curious
if even all of us are actually
stunningly and grossly under estimating
what's about to happen right so for
example shooting the [ __ ] here a little
bit retail like refill is about to get
way worse like like when it's like it's
pretty interesting the meetings I'm in
like if people think what you know
what's going to happen in retail one
little premise of the prediction this is
a flat-out guess but this has been
running through my mind the last hundred
days which is there's a lot of retailers
that are going out of business
and all of us look at them and go yeah
that makes sense yeah that makes sense
if we god-forbid have a retailer that
seemingly is healthy go out of business
in the next six months
it really just collapses that whole
infrastructure every day everybody knows
here what's happening with their
behavior right and so we've seen this
happen in different sectors but then I
was like okay retail it's in a really
scary place because if you care about
big data and analytics we're starting to
get to that threshold where there's
enough direct consumer business
happening online but basically the
infrastructure of reese's and those
really get scary and will clearly play
out it's not going backwards you know
every trend that we're living through
it's not coming back you know I'm in a
ton of [ __ ] meetings with
trillion-dollar companies who new game
plan is tried and true which is always
the pale pale - it's [ __ ] over
right because they're hoping and so
retail cool next a place where I'm far
more confident of what I'm talking about
which is media we have traditional media
companies whether their plan to Hearst
Conde or you know Viacom you know and a
box be put the cages upon let's we've
got another 24 to 36 months but when you
talk about being building knowledge and
TV advertising like that's going to play
out like it's over like OTT is real
Facebook comes out with its OTT product
in a month you know in the same way that
you didn't think you'd watch on Netflix
and told there was house of cards you
don't think you're going to watch a
sitcom or show on Facebook until
something comes out that you are gonna
wash and so you know today with Alexa I
mean like when you look at the gangster
level in which Facebook and Amazon are
innovating not giving a [ __ ] about Wall
Street and short-term ROI and investing
for the long term it's just very clear
to everybody smarten hear what I'm what
I'm curious about though is are we just
under estimating the whole thing in the
internet now hitting real maturity 20 to
23 years at the consumer internet 1995
windows 95 normal people went on another
some nerds in here but normal people
went on around that time you know and so
are we just hitting that crescendo
moment because you've got incredible
trends when I think about CPG brands and
the absolute fascination I have over the
next decade of watching the biggest
brands of the world prospered Unilever
J&J coca-cola Pepsi go through channel
conflict wars with Walmart and Costco
and target like DTC is putting so much
pressure the Internet is the middleman
and bookstores and black card services
just got caught first and so
everything's coming I have sat in my
office on the 25th floor of this
beautiful building in the last hundred
days and have sat down with bounders
group started direct consumer fashion
brands that have gone from 0 to between
3 and 10 million dollars in revenue in
one year on the back of having
pretty people on Instagram posts about
it when you start understanding and this
is this is my macro for all of us I
think everybody here needs to start
understanding that every incumbent is
not going to lose to another incumbent
they're losing by the death of a
thousand cuts but it's not that Ralph
Lauren which Ralph Lauren which is you
know going through it's going it's not
that I'll be a mage or coaches putting
them out of business it says that
there's 4,000 brands that I can do for
million dollars in revenue next year and
that [ __ ] adds up and that's just
happening everywhere we're living
through the long tail it's even
happening in the most innovative places
there's a lot of people here that have
not quantified how underpriced
influencer marketing is yet yet even in
that world destruction has come because
the long tail influencers of 25 to 15
thousand followers are starting to
disrupt the people that are overpriced
with a million followers I mean it's
happening so fast I'm watching very
smart people jump into things three
years our third actually happened with
four years ago talk and that creates
enormous disruption and so I guess the
one thing I would say again seeing a lot
of faces that I know here so we've got
real top to bottom CEOs of
billion-dollar companies people that are
starting startups I think we really need
to calibrate several things which is
there's an obnoxious amount of
opportunity because people are under
under valuating where the attention is
the attention is in the cell phone our
cell phone is the remote control of our
lives period end of story there's
nothing remotely close to as important
as a cell phone and when you start
understanding it over 50 percent of the
time spent on a cell phone is spent on
seven to ten core apps which are social
networks and growing YouTube in there
whatever you want to call it we talk
about more than half of the time we
spent on cell phones on things called
Facebook Twitter Instagram
and YouTube and all of a sudden social
media goes away from being a slang term
that people think is an afterthought or
a sprinkle and it starts becoming the
foundation of communication in our
society and so I implore and one of the
things that I'm very fascinated by so
for example I think Facebook videos are
the great underpriced opportunity to
change your business so if I'm a SAS b2b
business in this room doing five hundred
million dollars in revenue instead of
getting groups at trade shows and buying
ads and beauty magazines I know that I
could run a video on Facebook that's two
minutes and 18 seconds long as a target
employees of any company I want and the
copy and the opening line of the video
could be does your CIO know and I know
that that CIO will then get seven
hundred people or seventeen people or
she will get fourteen people sending
that video and that becomes a gateway to
business development people just not
practitioners this room is filled with
people who have a whole lot of things to
say about stuff but have never seen done
it there's a lot of opinions here of
buying snapchat filters in the open
market there's a lot of opinions here if
you like that and I say it because I do
it in every other thing that I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
right I've got a point on everything and
and but what's been a fascinating is
that people got opinions on what's
actually happening but they're not
practitioners we have a massive
disconnect between headline reading and
practitioner shift in the modern day of
running businesses and marketing and
that is an enormous arbitrage of
opportunity and it's also the preview to
a whole lot of carnage and so I don't
know I think uplift and I as somebody
who's most comfortable in chaos like
this is going to be the best like I
definitely want Wall Street to melt I
want I'm so tired of all these peacetime
generals we've seen deals that have been
navigating the last seven years of good
times I think we need a massive
correction of inaccurate and in that
correction there will be an enormous
opportunity because the biggest brands
in the world overhead and
structure is based on a world that
doesn't exist anymore and you know
what's funny
the 13 to 15 faces that I'm able to
actually see with the lighting you all
know I can see it you all know I'm not
so smart
I'm just saying and I'm saying it not
because I'm noble but because my
economics aren't tied up in it and so
one thing I would tell this extreme
smart group is the most fascinating
thing about the last 20 years of my
career is that people say [ __ ] they
don't believe because of short-term
economics which eliminates all their
long-term economic opportunities and so
this group needs to debate that this
really is filled with that and in that
is outrageous opportunity so if you work
somewhere and you believe something else
I highly recommend you put it on the
record because everybody in that room
will remember when [ __ ] hits the fan and
the people that are historically right
wins and that is going to be very
important for your actual livelihood
right now you may be pandering to what's
good for your livelihood for your voters
right now but when [ __ ] hits the fan you
get negated and debt it's a detriment
for being historically incorrect so I
would implore everybody to look at the
macro math to understand what's really
going on in the world where kylie jenner
got paid 1.3 million dollars last week
to purchase one picture on Instagram and
snapchat and guess what it was a good
[ __ ] deal it was and so I think
people are holding on to a reality that
doesn't exist anymore so I'm pumped
and I hope you are too because you are
that means that you haven't bobbed that
you know people love to make with a
client CMO and she was razzing on retail
and I was like but you're doing the same
thing with your corporate career and
your infrastructure your golden
handcuffs are their leases so I don't
know I think it's interesting time and
and I really appreciate your attention
I'd love to do a little Q&A if anybody's
interested so thanks for having me
anybody have any questions about
anything randomly yourself owe me a
favor
yes I think all of them with those bones
72 came out yes I don't take those after
clinic wasting they might never even
work but one happy one the night 7:00 to
10:00 p.m. I want I am so I have no
[ __ ] idea
you know I get a lot of credit because I
was early an investor in facebook and
twitter and snapchat and these things
but they were already they already made
it like the only thing I do is I'm a
practitioner I think it's a good idea to
wake up in the morning and look at the
top 200 apps in the App Store app boy
and look at data and download the app
and play with it like I'm not I'm not
guessing these things have already made
it
I'm just moving a little bit faster than
the rest of the market right now I don't
think they're time wasters because I
think escapism is a core need for human
beings right so whether it's reading a
book or watching TV I think I watch
grown men run into each other you know
because I love football but that's my
escapism from my right so I didn't judge
people doing that thing you know it's
funny I don't care right I think way too
many people here debate and have a
romantic point of view of how they want
the world to be I just react to the way
the world is actually
like Who am I to judge I was told as a
kid playing video games was a waste of
time I'm watching kids making 15 million
dollars a year play eSports [ __ ] changes
right and so I think that I'm I'm not
sure but what I would say is this the
only great arbitrage to the Internet
itself that is even out there is VR but
as I was talking to somebody earlier I
believe that consumer VR is quite far
away like we you know I react to reality
nobody here knows somebody that's
spending three hours a day on VR
everybody here is spending seven hours a
day on their phone like when you start
adding up your time on the place we're
ready
in theory living in VR we're living
through although nearly people here went
hiking this weekend to take the selfie
to PR themselves for the press and
friend but there's consumer behavior
that is happening that we are grossly
under estimating to Ryan's exact nature
so I don't know about what I will tell
you is I betrayed attention my life
until I die will be why does fly matter
to eight-year-olds right why did
spinners happen why do people care about
logic and Russ why are they spending so
much time on Instagram like and I don't
judge I just reacted cell maybe past
life is a little you're in but how are
you hi hi so I know you have to stay
with blocks now there were some of your
favorite spots that you're like Canton
so I understand here the funny part is I
am obsessed with that space but I'm more
paying and like for example I don't
consume content like I'm not necessarily
using a bunch of box and I'm looking at
what's going on with like you know meat
courts and reddit and then some media
companies and then and then retailers
there's a small yogurt startup that's
got a real buddy messenger market soon
soon well but what's really weird about
the way I roll I don't spend much time
doing any of this [ __ ] I spent all my
time watching you do it
robot would I grow back to you with
everything you said
I'm a little bit more in sub school I'm
in any other question yes let's putting
over here
you know which with your keeping even up
high high high actually representing
dying or disability
yes over fun drama
listen I have a 15,000 square foot wine
store right across the river I'm in it
here because we will work it together
yeah we'll figure it out but we're
currently on wrong yes we additionally
has that they'll be down on 40 acid and
in Orson yes and you were created for 15
so if you think was an unveil and
inclusive network of doctors I was like
we give withdraw the imagine ransom a
little bit money - I'm super where your
business we've done some stuff like to
me it's interesting right in a world
where you can new and imported and Brady
and step you also are in a place where
you're not fully even supporting people
like Julio Jones because you have a long
tail and yet there's people even further
down the long tail that have had I think
that it's a sports endorsement and like
insane arbitrage that thing is the
ultimate arbitrage in our society so
it's a great business model I think that
most of your athletes at this point are
locked into contracts that grossly
overpaid them on their invoice because
we lock them in in a world that is
shifting so it's pretty really
interesting to see what you and your to
me competitors are going to get
obviously you clean we have direct
competitors in a shoot space go in a
different direction or go towards music
you know you know it's one thing for
reasons snapping it's another thing now
to watch Rihanna's in with Kumar like
this is real right and then back to what
I was talking about earlier there's a
ton of little
or things going on under you know
collaborations what bass is doing and
others and so on it's interesting I
think
Under Armour has a very traditional Nike
like movement I really do from afar I
think that will be how to put you want
to think I'm most excited about like as
a fan of business is to actually see
what you guys do over the next two or
three years cuz I think there's
opportunity for you identity as
incentive I think that's right the sort
of going on transportation is a face to
donkey mouth we're doing that way
building three and ultimately that would
be the privatization I think the
decision you have to make based on
what's most important but that's when
you overspend on things in an old world
so for me I'd much rather allocate three
hundred thousand dollars in production
and distribution around Julio Jones in
an Atlantic area that spend the
ridiculous production value to launch a
step current shoe during a commercial
during the NBA playoffs not that you're
right and I'm wrong or vice versa
I just think that's how it's going to
play out yes none thank you
[Applause]
[Music]